worried parents are bringing their
children to this clinic for treatment
as the cholera outbreak spreads the very
young are among the most at risk
maintaining stocks of life-saving
medical supplies is vital to preventing
further deaths we are going to start
giving the cholera vaccine uh we are
glad that Deborah wind assist us with
about 2 million doses of Cholera vaccine
and we expect the percentage in the next
uh two weeks there was a small crisis of
course we didn't have enough
fluids but I'm happy that as Government
we have managed to do program IB fluids
are worth over 200 million
Malawi's cholera Crisis began in March
after a series of tropical storms
the destruction of infrastructure and
contamination of Water Supplies caused
an outbreak that spread across the
country
the main risk factor that we had
established and the team has established
was a low
wash activities that's water and
sanitation issues there's low coverage
of flat drains along the shorelines
cholera is also on the rise elsewhere in
the world particularly in Haiti and
Syria the World Health Organization is
calling for more resources to deal with
the crisis the number of outbreaks has
forced them to lower their treatment
standards from two doses of vaccine to a
single dose we can't end the pandemic
because we're not prepared collectively
to put in place the basic human rights
of water and sanitation and basic
immunization in those areas at risk and
it's a sad day for us to have to go
backwards to go to a one door strategy
which is life-saving it's an emergency
measure we shouldn't have to do it and
it is purely based on the availability
globally of vaccine
Malawi is doing what it can to contain
the outbreak but it's a Race Against
Time
rainy season is set to begin in November
creating conditions when diseases like
cholera can spread even faster
Vinton Monahan Al Jazeera